Michael Sanders on you Benton okay
misses you three yeah and then the name
of your project and your website the
name of the film is torn app and the
website is tone-deaf movie com so why
should we see till death because it is a
very funny film and if you like to laugh
and you like to be entertained for seven
minutes this is your chance okay and how
did you secure funding for the film what
we pay for it ourselves and as you guys
expect to get your funding back your
fight you know the investment back
that's a great question yes answer we
hope so that'll be the icing on the cake
and then how are you guys promoting it
we're using all the typical social media
that's out there on facebook and our
website YouTube what have you word of
mouth and that's like these
Oh